actually let me let me show you the
polls for for the sake of this end of
the segment I'll just show you right
here that 18 to 29 year olds
overwhelmingly favored Democrats so to
all of you I bid you farewell as you go
off to fight this war for me I don't
want you to be able to get drafted so
it's eight they say eight to twenty five
however they get drafted right but but
when it comes to actual War they
definitely broaden the yeah so they'll
they'll buy script 50 year olds it's not
it's not it's practicality but let's
let's talk about the story there's good
news I suppose if you don't like War
it's not necessarily absolute great news
because neocons Republicans have their
War mongers as well but the New York
Times says Republicans gain Edge as
voters worry about economy time Siena
pole finds here's what I find
interesting right now a bunch of polls
are dropping and they've mirror inverted
on their findings two weeks ago it's
like Democrats plus five and that's flip
Democrats plus five and I'm like whoa
whoa how is this happening in this man
of a week maybe it was all propaganda BS
and the pollsters are lying they're
really bad at their jobs that one's true
because they keep getting it wrong or
maybe Joe Biden tried a quid pro quo
with Saudi Arabia it backfired gas
prices are now skyrocketing right before
the election surprise Biden now we're
getting the October surprise and people
are saying no and the economy it's the
economy stupid so there we go what do
you think Republicans going to take it
now the polls are shifting or are they
always going to take it or I mean or do
they lose I don't know
well if Republicans win then they'll
announce that they're in a recession
right now about that yeah well actually
no that that's gonna be a bad thing
because that's when things will get
really bad yeah because the media will
say now we're in recession and then the
rich people will stop spending get
scared but it's already happening but
you're right the media won't admit it
they're going well we're not really in a
recession the the day after the election
if they announce Republicans take the
house they go oh it's a recession by the
way and they change the definition of
recession on Wikipedia correct well they
well this is the interesting thing
colloquially we have always called it
two periods two quarters of negative
growth but it's never been an official
governmental definition so now they're
playing a semantic game where of course
the president's administrations have in
the past even Pelosi as recent as I
think earlier this year all defined a
recession as two quarters of negative
growth the moment it happens for
political reasons they go no no no
that's not the real definition right so
it's all Bs take a look at this though I
find this really interesting so in the
polling
likely voters 49 to 45 favoring
Republicans men 50 to 45 women 47-47 so
women are split but dudes are five
percent more Republican what I find
really interesting is that 18 to 29 year
olds 52 favored Democrats 30 to 44 50
favorite Democrats 45 to 64 is 38 for
Democrats and then you have 65 and older
which is 48 to 48. so the interesting
thing is the only demographic by age
which opposes Democrats is 45 to 64.
does that mean for there's more 45 to 64
year olds than 30 to 40 than 18 to 44
year olds I wouldn't be surprised if
people aren't having kids but how is it
that 18 to 44 these two different age
groups overwhelmingly favor the
Democrats but 45 to 64 is almost two to
one Republican and that results in a 49
lead for Republicans over 45. is Gen xer
is just a bigger generation or something
or what is that some boomers are in
there I guess
I don't know I find it interesting but
like the oldest age group gets more
lived out I don't understand yeah well I
I was pulled in this I was saying this
early I was actually pulling this I've
never been pulled before I didn't think
they actually pulled conservative well
I'm I'm not a registered Republican so
maybe that had something to do with it
I'm ready no but this is all likely
voters this is all yeah yeah you
probably said you're favoring Republican
yeah yeah how old are you I'm 39. oh
okay so I'm in that yeah I don't trust
that it's only 792 likely voters it's
like a nut it's not that good of a
sample size getting over a thousand is
typically better it's not it's not the
worst but it's low yeah but here's the
other interesting Factor this is
National this is not Swing Swing
districts
so when you look at actual swing
District polling if the national polls
are this bad and this includes safe blue
and safe red districts yo it's looking
apocalyptically bad for Democrats right
now with like a couple weeks before the
midterm election
good good news I don't know well you
know I'm skeptical of both political
parties especially with how much uh
disastrous foreign policies came from
Republicans and right Wingers all
throughout the last few years there is a
battle within the party so it's going to
be interesting to see how it plays out
any politician I just I I just see them
I said this before the show all as
welfare Queens I'm not a fan of any of
them is it going to really change things
maybe maybe not but I'm I'm more I'm I'm
more skeptical I do believe the real
change is going to happen with
individuals losing faith in the
institutions and becoming more
personally responsible for themselves
and making the right decisions with
every small action that they make
whether it's their thoughts whether it's
their dollar whether it's their vote and
I think truly on a local level it's
going to matter a lot more so is this
going to matter is this going to change
our perspective I don't know I see the
Baseline Republican party going along
with you know the the the coveted
policies the the war policies and I
don't see much changing from it to be
honest with you I mean I kind of feel
like there's at least enough good
Republicans who are running who are
going to block a lot of these efforts
the issue is half the Republican party
is establishment chills even if the
Republicans get a majority those
Republicans will vote with Democrats in
favor of War and the house will keep
funding all this stuff yeah the Lindsey
Grahams the Mitt Romney's uh are
definitely peculiarly are Republicans to
say the least uh but there hasn't really
been a full shift and there's been a big
pushback against a lot of the populist
Republicans that actually do talk about
what people want and need and and talk
about the changes that would actually
make a difference here but to me you
know I'm just a skeptical skeptical
person so I could just be too
pessimistic are you guys optimistic or
pessimistic there is the new wave of
like the Kerry Lakes coming up and that
looks hopeful but I mean yeah
traditionally like Republicans don't
ever really do [ __ ] when they're in
power so it doesn't exactly make me
hopeful to see that and think things are
going to change but interestingly though
oh sorry they're kind of the party that
just sits on their butt 100 I'm sorry
but our our our populists are vary
Against The Establishment and speaking
out against us as you said of course the
establishment still in the way but look
at the left look at their so-called
populace like the the progressives the
squad people yeah they just fall right
in line you know if you had a coalition
between the aocs who should be against
this kind of stuff and the Marjorie
Taylor greens who knows what could be
accomplished but they're they're whipped
by Nancy Pelosi and
there you have it yeah it's gonna be
their fault we're going to war it's
gonna be the populace left you know I
kind of feel like there's a strong
possibility Pelosi won't be in office
after this yeah well maybe the
speakership I don't know is she she's
not playing on retiring she said she's
running for re-election right yeah yeah
I believe so and then there's no way she
loses in that District but I wonder I
don't know if she'll be speaker
that that's I'm just hearing scuttlebutt
that it sounds like
you know for
the Democrats they're not expecting that
to be to be Pelosi is it because she's
going to pass away or something like
that why do you think what's the reason
no because we're probably gonna win
Republicans win they'll just they'll
vote for somebody else so uh but we'll
see I mean does that mean it's Kevin
McCarthy I don't know I'm just hearing
some Scuttle but behind the scenes that
it sounds like preparations are like
there's an expectation I just put it
that I can't I don't want to you know
without any Source or anything but it
sounds like there's expectation that she
will not be speaker at the very least
and maybe not even be in office although
that seems like a longer shot it just
seems like she's not going to be speaker
of the house it's going to be
interesting to see uh because it's
definitely a very fast-changing
political landscape Anything Could
Happen we're still you know in October
there could be a lot of surprises coming
our way I think there will be uh it's
already been an absolutely crazy news
cycle I think it's only going to get a
lot crazier from here oh man you know
that's the thing we're we talked about
this before October surprises how many
October surprises have there already
been Tulsa gambard quits the Democratic
party launches a show right in October
so they want they want uh six months in
jail for Steve Bannon they're pushing
and 200 000 fine what else do what else
Crystal Walker Herschel Walker was it oh
yeah yeah abortion thing yeah yeah yeah
it's just it's it's like a machine gun
of October surprises it's just not gonna
stop
I wonder if they tried to make the Roger
Stone thing one like just hoping people
would fall for it oh yeah the Roger
Stone thing yeah that was crazy we'll
talk about that one in a second too but
we've got a whole bunch of October
surprises and I wonder if any of it
really messed oh the Nancy Pelosi thing
where she's like this yourself
I can't believe they thought that was
that supposed to be good for Democrats
yeah Nancy Pelosi saying she was waiting
for trespassing at the Capitol that like
like she wanted it to happen I mean they
loved it though if you look at like all
the blue check Libs posting about it
they were yes queening about it yeah
but she's saying she expected it to
happen right it had a camera crew yeah
that's interesting
what's the official story for why she
had a camera crew did they even bother
thinking of an excuse it's just it was
there I don't understand yeah well a lot
of people expected a lot of problems and
a lot of people yeah there's a lot of
protests there's a lot of websites there
was a lot of people saying yeah we're
gonna go do this and we're going to
college trouble so I I absolutely she
was ready she she's the queen of Insider
information so you gotta understand she
knows that Warren Buffett doesn't even
know right so she's a very powerful lady
with a lot of money with a lot of
influencers in the Game of Thrones they
have that uh that Minister part of the
Round Table that's the the minister of
Whispers that's pretty much Nancy Pelosi
that's who she is yeah uh she she knows
everything before it even happens so
obviously that's a really good idea for
a skit maybe Sheamus could do this one
for Freedom Tunes where it's like it's a
carnival and you go to Plants you go to
palanci what I call her Clancy you go to
Pelosi's she's got like a cart and you
go inside it and she reads your fortune
tells you the future you should invest
in Tesla right now why just trust me
then she turns around and she's like I
vote Yes on the bill to support more
Tesla funding and then it's like the
people are like wow she was right I made
a fortune she's a psychic that's how it
goes man I'm impressed that she keeps
doing like you no matter how many times
anyone complains about it be on the left
the left and the right are complaining
about these these these Congress people
senate or house who just make all the
right bets yeah right when they need to
make it happen for some reason right
yeah yeah and there's little support on
Banning uh members of Congress from from
Trading almost I wonder why absolutely
or regulations or accountability or some
transparency no there's so many like
viral Tech talks people just investing
exactly what Nancy Pelosi does and just
apparently yeah did they really yeah
that's so disgusting wow thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there